- Now that you've lied to the
police, what are you gonna do?
- I'm going to Disney World.
- A mom who faked her own kidnapping
and went to Disney World
is now facing fraud charges
for ripping off her employer.
Bonnie Sweeten first rose to fame in 2009
when she engineered a kidnapping hoax.
Sweeten called 911 and said that she
and her daughter had been
carjacked by two Black men.
She claimed to be calling
from the trunk of the kidnapper's car.
This triggered a massive
manhunt, and one day later
authorities found out that Sweeten
and her daughter were actually hanging out
at a luxury resort at Walt
Disney World in Orlando.
Now, Sweeten eventually
was sentenced to 9 months
in jail for the hoax, but
she wasn't done criming.
In 2012, she stole over $1 million
while working as a paralegal.
She was sentenced to 100
months in federal prison
for her crimes.
Her latest problem arose
when she allegedly stole
from an excavating company
where she had worked
as a bookkeeper since 2017.
Sweeten allegedly stole checks
which she then fraudulently
endorsed over to herself.
She's charged with two
counts of wire fraud, and
if convicted Sweeten faces a
maximum of 40 years in prison.
I mean, if you can't trust
someone who has engaged
in decades of fraud, who can you trust?